am cern im größten teilchenbeschleuniger
der welt wurde ein neuer rekord
aufgestellt zwei protonen sind mit nie
gekannter energie aufeinander geprallt
und ihr da werden auch neue rekorde
aufgestellt das ist nämlich die formel
die weltmeisterschaft der elektro
rennwagen hier in berlin
und da gibt es eine menge innovative
technologien und das und mehr jetzt in
den news pics zum science fiction
ja hier bei der formel e da sind ja
genau an der stelle wo die wagen gekühlt
werden und zwar mit trockeneis und
laubbläsern die die kalte luft des
trocken eises nicht in den motor sondern
in die batterien bläst denn das ist
eines der empfindlichsten teile bei
elektro rennwagen hier werden nämlich
ich sag mal handelsübliche akkus
eingebaut die es auch in handys gibt
dass es genau die gleiche technologie
und die werden wie ihr wisst von eurem
eigenen handy wenn eine app startet die
viel rechenpower braucht die werden
richtig heiß und deswegen wenn die waage
ihre runden gedreht haben dann müssen
sie erstmal gekühlt werden
diese und noch viele mehr technologien
die sehr innovativ sind werden hier
eingesetzt bei der formel dazu gibt es
ein spezielles video am nächsten
dienstag bei pixum science fiction
forscher der tu münchen und der
physikalisch technischen bundesanstalt
berlin haben einen raum geschaffen in
dem das erdmagnetfeld fast komplett
abgeschirmt ist es ist nur noch ein
billionstel so stark wie zb bei euch zu
hause und mit diesem raum wie immer neue
messungen durchführen können und besser
erfahren dass wenige sekunden nach dem
urknall passiert ist kürzlich vollzogene
ausgrabungen brachten hilfswerk zeuge
hervor die vor 33 millionen jahren
genutzt worden sind das heißt der mensch
der homo sapiens er war nicht das erste
lebewesen auf unserem planeten das
bereits werkzeuge benutzt hat anhand von
knochenfunden in äthiopien konnten
forscher bereits fest verletzungen
feststellen wie eben durch werkzeuge
erzeugt worden sind und die sind eben
einige millionen jahre alt am lhc das
ist der größte teilchenbeschleuniger der
welt mehrere kilometer lang am cern in
genf ist ein neuer rekord aufgestellt
worden und zwar kollidierten in der
nacht vom 20
auf den 21 zwei protonen mit einer noch
nie zuvor erzeugte energie im lhc
miteinander mit 13 tera-elektronenvolt
im juni schon sollen die ersten daten
über diese starke errungenschaft
veröffentlicht
das ist wirklich eine wissenschaftliche
erkenntnis dies für uns alle
mega wichtig auf hefe kann man
wahrscheinlich drogen machen und das
geht folgendermaßen forscher haben sich
bei einer analyse von hefe sind ja auch
interessante dinge gestoßen
die hilfe produziert nämlich in
kombination mit enzymen die glukose
enthalten rieti zu lean und ritalin
findet man auch zum beispiel im schlaf
mond und der ist für die herstellung von
opiaten wird er verwendet und um hilfe
in diesem bereich wirklich nutzen zu
können müsste man allerdings die
ausbeute noch für tausendfachen also
alarm ende jetzt zum größten
teilchenbeschleuniger der welt dem lhc
findet ihr in diesem video
wie immer gibt es aktuelle news und
infos in der app und im block dafür
müsste hier klicken
und was meint ihr gehört die hefe
demnächst unter das
betäubungsmittelgesetz und müsste
vielleicht verboten werden
schreibt uns diskutiert in die
kommentare was soll man überhaupt an
drogen verbieten und was soll erlaubt
werden
ich bin auf die diskussion sehr gestand
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran